hey everybody time for another movie
retrospective that's right Candyman you
know what I was thinking when I was
thinking about doing this movie I said
if we say Candyman five times during the
course of this review does that mean
he's gonna appear behind us and get us
with his hook yeah Candyman when it was
new I think we rented it on v8 on VHS
when it came out what year was this
again 92 it came in I need to cuz I saw
it in the theater it's almost been in
the Army at the time yeah not yet
surprises rented it from you know with
the rental place that we had I remember
like it it's a great [ __ ] movie and I
feel like it's one that kind of gets
forgot about a lot now I'm gonna say
right here that you know I I love horror
from all eras but I do feel like the
early 90s really a little bit of a
wasteland there were some good ones in
there but if I felt like after scream
came out you know after dal ah'd of the
horror movies that 90s went in that kind
of like ironic slasher sort of direction
and so it's you know so it's notable to
me that Candyman which came out in 1992
which on its surface kind of sounds like
a slasher but it's really not want to
gothic horror it is it is kind of like a
gothic horror story it and it's um for
real like kind of like a precursor to
like make Jordan peels movies
particularly get out he definitely has
that 90s tone to it if you have a Neil
Gaiman kind of story in 90s tone and you
you know you know if you grew up in this
era or you went through this era you
recognize it immediately yeah it's good
it's good to revisit these old movies it
was it was enjoyable to watch it is slow
by today's standards but gothic horror
was like that it does build up to it to
a cool ending it
it's very Dracula like it is a bit in
the structure of the story kinda the
character Candyman is kind of like a
Dracula he's a ghost version of a
Dracula well in the sense too
he's clearly a villain and he's scary
but he's also kind of sympathetic
because you get like some of his
backstory and you can understand like
why he's pissed off yeah and you know
and he's a he's a flying pretty
[ __ ] you know it's kind of
intimidating like a Dracula yeah he's
like a Dracula but what's good is it you
know in terms of you know if you ever go
back to see the old 70s version Blacula
which I love the both those two movies
actually they're they're really good
they're much better than you think that
they they were that they would be by the
titles you know influenced and rice in
this case instead of copying Dracula and
just making him a black vampire this is
a totally unique character I like that
part of this yeah for real
Candyman is his own thing that's the
thing it's like I really like because I
really like in general like things that
are based around urban legends cuz I've
always found that sort of thing very
fascinating so I mean the original story
was by Clive Barker and it was called
the forbidden now this was also a you
know Clive Barker's obviously a Brit now
the writer and director of this the guy
who wrote the screenplay
Bernard Rose was also British but he
decided in the original story by Clive
Barker which I read many years ago it
was actually set in kind of a slum in
Liverpool and the Candyman character
even there is an urban legend there is
that whole aspect to it you know but the
Candyman character was actually a really
pale white dude with like long blonde
hair and he had like a patchwork kind of
outfit that and he would kind of appear
but they didn't have I mean obviously
once the story was moved to the u.s.
specifically Chicago yeah they adapted
it and based around the cook the
notorious cabrini-green you know kind of
projects which you know are still I
think they've been a bit gentrified now
but they certainly look cool in the film
used to tell you can tell that
everything is kind of like filmed
on-location oh it definitely wasn't it
has a feel you know you're in a real
place yeah it's not artificially real
busy there's a cars going around
everywhere it's it does have a really
good realistic
on a tone in a way but the colors are
sometimes kind of comic book II colors
it's good it's out I liked I liked the
execute and like you said it's almost
like a I mean and in the way that the um
that this building is shot I mean
obviously I mean people still live in it
but it's you know it's been taken over
by gangs mostly it's like there's
graffiti everywhere but the way it's
shot is very gothic like you did like
the angles of it like just kind of the
way it's shot looks a lot like that
almost like a Cathedral sort of which i
think was kind of a cool aspect to the
movie yeah it just has a cool well
executed look and feel to the movie and
it's very much something of the 90s but
the good better quality of the nineties
not cheap like I said this is easily one
of my favorite horror movies from the
90s I mean to be fair not a lot of
audition in that area about it it's not
quite as as as pretty as Dead Ringers
but it's still yeah it's still cool
flick yeah definitely yeah but the thing
about it okay so let's talk a little bit
I have to say too that it's like this
has a great [ __ ] cast Tony Todd
obviously as Candyman is [ __ ] amazing
wait mom dad why ringers but I think
that Flatliners were thinking of dead
ringers I don't know they're one they
had had the real all-star cast and they
were Treme's a flatline flatline ER
suspend ringers was the David Collins
yeah I don't want to review one of these
days because I love them it's kinda up
there with Flatliners yeah not quite as
pretty as Flatliners but you can tell
that they're from that same era yeah you
know it just has a good tone I didn't
mean to interrupt you but you know how
it is and I'm [ __ ] brain but yeah it's
it's good flex it was good to revisit it
yeah but um Netflix just added it by the
way you know which is why we decided to
do it because I hadn't seen it in many
years and I was like really excited and
I was like ooh that's like a really good
movie and I feel like like I said I feel
like it's one that kind of gets
forgotten about even though it's super
excellent especially for that time
period when there was like kind of a
dearth of decent horror movies and like
I said they got a great [ __ ] cast
with this Tony Todd is incredible he is
like simultaneously intimidating and
terrifying but he's also you also
sympathize with him and he's also
seductive yeah he's a good-looking guy
and that [ __ ] Waterboys man
oh that there's only like two other
voices that can compare to his voice you
know and that's that's you know James
Earl Jones and Keith David Keith day
yeah that same kind of Keith David could
have done this role I think well you
know who they wanted for this originally
they really wanted anybody that would
not have worked you know but I
understand it though I understand I I
I'm a big fan of Eddie Murphy's I am too
but not not in the movie Lee and I liked
I liked his vampire movie yeah I did as
well I'm a huge fan of the first two
Beverly Hills Cop movie something that
grew up with those I even like the
golden child
yeah golden chalice great we bought that
the other day [ __ ] really but it's
weird and random as if he is it's a good
movie of his time and that was when
Murphy's career was still going strong
and they were just fun movies to watch
they weren't yeah they weren't supposed
to be you know and we're supposed to be
something that they weren't they were
just fun movies to watch and they were
well at well made and Beverly Hills Cop
manda one and two I [ __ ] loved him I
know yeah Axel Foley a great character
well like I said I feel like I mean the
fact that you know like I said Eddie
Murphy was the first choice they
couldn't afford him for this movie
because this wasn't like a huge budgeted
movie or anything like that and I think
that was for the good because I love
Eddie Murphy I'm not saying that but
it's just like I just don't think this
role would have worked the same with
Eddie Money not quite tall and scary I
mean he's not intimidating enough it's
like you always have that idea that he's
gonna bust into a joke even as his
vampire movie yet if he was kind of
snarky and like you could tell you could
tell that it was Eddie but he did a good
job I'm just saying whereas in in
Candyman I mean a Tony Todd who I think
was if I'm remembering correctly and
it's been a long time since I've seen it
I think he was also in the 1990 remake
of Night of the Living Dead yes which is
actually pretty decent Myra Thompson
beany directed it was named possession
was talk Tony Todd yeah yeah yeah
and you know this is really the only
role I associate
I was in night 11 dead and what else
I think he was in the night of Living
Dead remake from 1990 thank you he's
been at a bunch of other movies too and
he was actually in the sequels to this
which we're not going to talk about
because they were sure like they're
really not very good but um you know
what I mean but fair play to him this
was this is kind of like his iconic you
know a lobby's he's been a bunch of
other stuff but who did Eddie Murphy
have pulled this up okay now with Eddie
Murphy billing on it it would have
gotten more at the box office it
probably would have well yeah that's
what they were shooting for but yeah
would it have remained a classic cult
classic I don't think it would have now
although yeah what was the name of Eddie
Murphy's vampire movie again a vampire
in Brooklyn and Bram Brooklyn I got it
on blu-ray need to say it again yeah we
watched it not too long ago I like that
movie too well like I said it's you know
it's just not it's not on the same
because this movie this is a very
serious movie you know what I mean this
is a film right even though I think and
it's funny cuz I was watching um this
other guy's review of it I can't
remember what channel it was on but he
was like a younger guy but he likes like
a lot of older movies but he had never
got around to seeing this one because he
thought it was just like a standard 90
slasher movie and then he watched it and
he was like holy [ __ ] this is like a
great [ __ ] movie he's like not just a
great horror movie this is a great movie
period yeah I mean like the writing is
so good the script is so good
the villain is so good just the whole
backstory of it is great the story the
the way the story is cottom way it kind
of moves along and everything it reminds
I put it on what I would put this on par
with the first Hellraiser yeah about
like that and in some ways like that was
good because that was a great movie for
its time I mean I love Clive Barker film
adaptations of his work tend to be very
hit or miss but Hal razor and Candyman
are easily the best and honestly some
days I like candy made better than the
answer it just depends on what the same
guy that wrote it in it yes yeah that's
right yes I always get Clive Barker and
Neil Gaiman they kind of
merged together for some reason I guess
it was because they were in the same era
and I was watching I guess yeah even
though the tones of those neil gaiman is
more fan of fantasy based but this one
kind of had that kind of fantasy dark
fantasy tone to it i watching it I kept
thinking of Neil Gaiman yeah but it did
also feel like Clive Barker with that
damn you know that razor wanted yeah
yeah it was kind of like a mixture of
them both but for some reason this had
kind of a
maybe it's because you said it kind of
had that seductive seductive level or
feeling to it it seemed a little fantasy
yeah you know not quite as oppressive as
the way Hellraiser was held a resident
was pretty [ __ ] weird
rusty for the time yeah now it's kind of
tame hellraisers but well I remember
like the big deal when I came out and I
remember reading books of blood when I
was a kid and just being [ __ ] blown
away cuz I had never read anything like
that ever there like in anything I'd
read all kind of different horror but
that was first time I never anything
like that but so as I was saying a long
time ago um the cast of this is like
really really good Virginia Madsen is
kind of the main character and she is
playing a she's a graduate student named
Helen Lyle and she is writing her thesis
her and her friend Bernadette he's
played by Casey lemons who I've also she
was in Silence of the Lambs too if I'm
remembering correctly but um so they're
doing their thesis on urban legends now
they get really interested in they're
from Chicago they're kind of from the
right side of the tracks people yeah
they're well Casey loans is on it one of
them is but they're like milk yeah but I
think the black girls from the right
side tracks that's what I mean yeah so
so there's that kind of thing going on
so they hear about this urban legend
called Candyman that's been going around
the residence of cabrini-green and he's
being he's like a mythical figure that
is being attributed you know it that
like all these burgers in this place are
being attributed to him now how a mile
you know being a college you know
grad grad student and stuff like that
she is coming at it through the lens of
well the people that live in this
building they live in these horrible
conditions their life isn't so great and
stuff like that so they are using this
urban legend this myth of this guy with
a hook through her hand that comes
through your mirror if you say his name
five times they're using that to deal
with like the shitty conditions that
they live in so she's coming out she's a
sympathetic character also but she's
coming at it from a little bit of like a
privileged place where it's like oh you
know they're just you know they're
talking mom they don't know you know
they're just using it it's not real and
all this other kind of stuff
now the interesting thing too is that
they juxtaposed and I'm not sure a lot
of people catch this but there is a
scene in the where you know Helen Lyle
lives with her creepy philandering
husband who's played by Xander Berkeley
he's like a professor at the same
College and they live in this on the
other side of the tracks like I said in
Chicago like in the nice part of town
but she finds out that the building she
lived in was built as a housing project
but then when her neighborhood started
to gentrified they fancied it up and
made it look more like you know middle
to upper class because that's how she
finds out that the bathroom mirrors like
in between the apartments like pop out
and there's no wall in between yeah she
meant you know the the apartments that
are right up against each other to share
common walls the dam the medicine
medicine cab in the back you pull one
out you'll see the back one others you
can just push that out yeah that's what
the in evidently this is based on some
real [ __ ] that happened well yeah I was
just gonna mention that because in the
movie she says they find out about this
murder of a woman named brucey gene that
was killed in cabrini-green by a man who
busted in through her bathroom mirror
and they're attributing this to the
Candyman now this is absolutely based on
a real case
Ruthie McCoy and she was 52 years old
and an intruder came in through her bath
like popped out the bathroom mirror and
crawled is just like in the [ __ ]
movie came out through the mirror and
shot her now she actually called the
cops like while he was coming through
and she she said something like he you
know there's a tree he's
through the bathroom or he's coming in
through the cabinet or something like
that named Blair they didn't believe her
they didn't know what she was talking
about it's like the cops actually came
to her apartment like a while later you
know I mean cuz they're like oh it's the
hood who cares so it's like so they go
there and they knock on the door she
doesn't answer so they leave and then
later on a neighbor hears right gunshots
yeah and calls the cops again and then
finally they wandered their asses over
there and she I don't think he even got
found for two days thought she was crazy
yeah I said if man was coming to them
what's coming through the mirror but he
was busted out the [ __ ] long imagina
they even met maybe she maybe she
actually thought he came through the
mirror well maybe she did if she you
didn't know yeah she's like I would
probably have a [ __ ] heart attack if
I saw somebody because if I didn't know
that the mirror popped out cuz why would
you blow your [ __ ] mind
it would that's what I'm here maybe she
actually believed it yet right so the
interesting thing about this is that as
um you know Helen and her friend
Bernadette as they kind of start to
interview because obviously the people
that live in Cabrini Green are very like
you know they don't want to talk to them
at first but finally she kind of gets
this one woman to talk to like this one
young girl I want to talk to her and
like he she gets this little boy named
Jake to talk to her and they're and Jake
tells her story about Candyman
killing a little boy in this like gross
ass bathroom that's like on the grounds
and like cutting his penis off and
leaving it in the toilet and so Helen
being either really brave or incredibly
stupid like goes into this bathroom to
like check it out and take pictures
there's like [ __ ] you know stuff written
on the walls and [ __ ] and also it's like
the disgusting Trainspotting bathroom
and so while she's in there this guy
comes in and says to her right here
you're looking for Candyman [ __ ] and
he's got a hook for a hand or like he's
holding a hook in his hand and he knocks
her ass out so for a while she thinks
she's right because this gang member has
taken on the mantle of Candyman in order
to like instill fear in the people that
cuz he's like a drug dealer yeah like
that and of course that ain't Candyman
but of course it's not and so as the
story progresses because of course like
very early in the story like
and Bernadette like go in the bathroom
mirror and say his name five times they
don't think it's gonna now Bernadette
chickens out like after the fourth time
and like Ellen ends up saying it by
herself but nothing happens at first so
they think oh it's just all fun and
games everything like that but then
later on in the movie and it takes about
halfway through the movie I think it's
like it's a 45 or 50 minute mark and
Helen is in like the [ __ ] you know
parking garage or whatever and she's the
first glimpse of Candyman you just see
him standing way across the parking
garage and he has that [ __ ] voice and
he's like yeah now at some point earlier
in the film which I forgot to mention
this other professor when he hears that
Helen is working on is like studying the
Candyman method is gonna write her
thesis on it
he manse plains to her because yes he
did yeah he totally does like it's like
that it's like a textbook example of
man's leaning but um because she's been
going and doing field research so he's
like I already read a book about that a
long time ago let me tell you all about
it you know I mean so they're all eating
dinner and he tells the backstory of
Candyman cuz Candyman used to be a real
person he was a live guy and he was the
I believe he was the son of a slave and
he actually kind of got prosperous by
coming up with some kind of like I don't
remember was like some kind of
innovation like in making shoes or
something like that so he actually did
pretty well for himself he was also a
painter and so he kind of like moved
around in high society like painting you
know portraits of all the society ladies
and stuff like that well unfortunately
for him he falls in love with a white
woman and gets my magnet white woman's
gonna be the downfall of many a man I'll
tell you that particularly okay
so even though you know the Hawaii toidy
hoi polloi or whatever yeah head bent
had previously been all about it oh he
does beautiful paintings and let them
paint all of his veil all of her their
family members and stuff once he falls
in love with a white woman she now she
loved him back it wasn't like a you know
it wasn't anything like that and got her
pregnant everybody in the town decided
they were going to lynch him in really
one of the most
always possible one they cut off his
painting hand I don't know if they stuck
the hook in there if he did that later
but then they smeared his whole entire
body with honey and he got stung to
death by bees while everyone watched
this was supposed to be in Chicago well
I'm not sure where that yeah what I mean
it might have been yeah so that's why
there's like so much B imagery and [ __ ]
like that and another thing kids that
have grown up with just CGI and [ __ ]
like that all the scenes in Candyman
that you see with bees coming out of
Toni Todd's mouth bees all over Virginia
Madsen's face like coming out his chest
that those are all real bee yeah he put
a lot of bees in his mouth and Virginia
Madsen was allergic to bee it still is
probably so she was terrified you're
sleeping there watching up going how the
hell'd they get that illusion to work it
wasn't an illusion illusion I'm looking
at ago yeah he does he just has a big
old wad of bees uh-huh that's happy
really back in the day that's hardcore
you gotta be careful don't bite down on
any of them well I heard this is what I
heard I don't remember where I heard
this room I heard that Tony Todd said
like said to the director of the
producers or whatever I want a thousand
dollars for every time that I get stung
yeah so he got stung 23 times so yeah
$23,000 Doris for all be back in those
days you could buy a car for that these
were supposed to be like sort of more
mellow bees you know what I mean because
be is they isn't like honeybees yeah
they're supposed to like knots too but
obviously if you're sticking the things
in your mouth yeah you're accidentally
gonna piss one of them and of course
yeah they're gonna be like that so yeah
so there's this whole story about
Candyman and like I said as it goes on
it seems like what Candyman does to
Helens character is since she's I guess
the only one that can see him so like he
starts kind of framing her for various
murders like she and she ends up in the
apartment of Ann Marie the first woman
that they talked to you in cabrini-green
Helen just wakes up in the apartment
with like a [ __ ] cleaver an extra
hand
there's a decapitated dog yeah uh
anne-marie is in there like screaming
her head off and her baby Anthony is
missing so they presumed that she is
kidnapped her
Candyman also murders her best friend
Bernadette and also Helen seems to
blackout and wakes up just in pools of
blood and doesn't know what's going on
pretty cool scene and it's it look like
a real dog's head sitting there it
really did it might have been they might
they might have got it from from the
pound from the pound or anything because
it really did look like a real dogs I
know guys I mean the thing about this
movie is that a lot of it you know it
plays out like kind of a supernatural
drama and at the point where Candyman
starts you know framing her for crimes
it becomes almost kind of like it's like
super frustrating because you kind of
know that she didn't do it the Candyman
is real but then again
do you really maybe she is just crazy
and maybe she did just kill all those
people because that's how it looks to
everyone else and she gets put in a
mental institution no one believes her
you know she says he's real and all this
other kind of stuff I never looked at it
that way though it could be interpreted
that way to interpret that way when I
was a kid I was just on I saw him yeah
yeah I mean must be really happy really
yeah well I mean and there's a scene
that the one scene that a lot of people
point to it's like oh yeah Candyman was
real well it's when she's in the office
talking to the psychiatrist and her
hands are bound like to the chair arms
yeah and she's like you know it wasn't
me it's like this orbital I know it
sounds crazy but it's like an urban
legend he came out of the mirror and he
kills people and he's like making it
look like I did it she's like I'll prove
it to you and she looks at a mirror in
the psychiatrist's office and says his
name five times and for a second nothing
happens and then Candyman comes up
behind the psychiatrist and BAM that
[ __ ] hook comes right through his
chest and like just [ __ ] guts him so
but the thing is
then after Candyman does that then he
cuts her restraints yeah so it's
possible she could have broken out on
her own and done that it's I don't know
because like I said you could interpret
it that way but it's much scarier to
think that
an urban legend guy that like only you
can see is like [ __ ] people up and it
looks like you did it that's like that's
like terrifying to me yeah you know what
I mean so yeah so obviously no one
believes her all this other kind of [ __ ]
now the cool thing that I what I like
about this movie is that it wasn't
afraid to have a downer ending yeah it
was kind of like a bummer ending yeah
now it's not quite as much my it was a
little bit different because I wish I
think this story the forbidden I think
actually the baby Anthony died at the
end which he doesn't in the movie I
remember when I remember back in 92 when
in this movie you know maybe might have
been 93 but I saw this movie when it was
still fresh I remember when we saw the
ending at that time was kind of like the
newish endings that you would get in
these new movies there yeah subversive
like yeah like he said it's kind of a
downer ending yeah it was a little bit
unusual but it did hit the times yeah
and everything the tone of the story I
mean it what ends up happening is that
Helen becomes part of the folklore that
she was exploring yeah because the
reason okay there are two reasons that
Candyman
targeted her specifically one because
she looked like the reincarnation of the
woman that he had fallen love with back
in the 1800s too because she had tried
to demystify him by exploring the urban
legend and saying that he wasn't real
and like talk and she helped get that
drug dealer arrested like near the
beginning of the movie that like was
taking on candy man's name and you know
trying to scare people that way so he
saw it as like as her trying to
demystify him and he seemed like he
needed people to believe in him like a
lot of the stuff that he said like in
voiceover like the movie it kind of like
it was kind of a thing where you have to
believe in me or I won't or I can't
exist you know what I mean so I feel
like at the end of it like she kind of
becomes part of the folklore and she
kind of becomes a Candy Man sort of
figure in her own right like one of the
best scenes in the movie is like at her
funeral and then like only a couple
people are there because of like keeping
her stupid husband and
stuff who's been cheating on her the
whole time but with like some 18 year
old student or whatever but um so
there's only a couple of people at the
funeral because everyone thinks she's a
crazy murderer and then they just cut
across to the cemetery and all the
people from Cabrini Green are just
coming in this big procession and they
and they throw like the little boy Jake
like throws the hook down onto her
coffin yeah
like said they're like respecting her
but also fearing her it's a good movie
it's well-made it's got a good score
it's got a good it's got a good acting
I've got a good script yeah but you got
to remember that this is gothic horror
yeah the Gothic horizont I'm with it god
it's gonna take its time there's gonna
be an element of romances style to it
it's almost like a [ __ ] up love story
yeah it kind it is and it's it's
actually kind of like a fucked-up
interracial love story yeah there's
definitely that angle cuz I remember
watching it back in 92 that was the
angle that that was like one of the main
selling angles yeah it's kind of like a
Dracula story but in this case instead
of a vampire it's a ghost and he's a
black guy yeah and it's a lot of same
things from the front from the original
Dracula alright I thought it's cool yeah
it is a very cool very cool movie it is
not scary by today's standards I was
saying it's not like a slasher it's not
even really that it's not worried its
gory and guard its it is it does have
blood but it is a gothic horror movie
and you know what I mean kind of like an
updated version of something you can see
from Hammer
yeah you know although like I said some
of the scenes particularly the scene
where the dog is killed and in the scene
where the psychiatrist gets killed like
by Candyman that's pretty gory and I
think it makes it worse some of the
scenes it makes it worse that you don't
see what actually happens you just see
the aftermath of it like you just see
blood everywhere like a dog head or
whatever but when the psychiatrist gets
killed one of the grossest things about
it is the sound effects and also
Candyman he's like grunting like he's
really [ __ ] getting in there you know
and she's just like tearing this [ __ ]
booth and it's like super nasty yeah and
he looks cool too he's kind of got this
big fur coat yeah it's like this really
big cut and he's a big
dude you know you can see he's got meat
where his damn wrists used to be hooked
coming out of it yeah it's big blood all
over that damn cuff you know kind of a
you know it's kind of an unsettling
thing and then like we opens his coat
and you can see his ribs and there's
[ __ ] yeah it's pretty cool it's awesome
it's like a really iconic yes look and I
feel like he's one of the most iconic
you know villains of the 90s I'm like I
said the horror in the 90s was a little
meh there wasn't like ya wouldn't know
what a lot of great [ __ ] going on um
should say to like you said you
mentioned the score the score for this
it was pretty good incredible done by
Philip Glass I also wanted to mention
too that Bernard Rose who direct who
wrote and directed this he also did a
movie I think he came out in 1988 that a
lot of people haven't seen but it's
called paper house and if you really
like these kind of like really weird
like little creepy movies and stuff go
check that [ __ ] out it's like really
really good and I and I feel like it
doesn't get a lot of attention but I saw
it a little while back because I saw it
like recommended on one of those
underrated horror movie typo lists that
I went and watched it I think I found it
for free on YouTube or to me or
something like that but that's also
really good it's not rates nothing like
Candyman but um you know it's still like
a cool movie in its own right but I
think that was like there was something
else I wanted to mention and now I can't
even like remember what it was Oh what I
did want to mention like I said this had
two sequels Candyman to farewell to the
flesh and Candyman 3 Day of the Dead I
think it was called neither of them are
really worth watching even though Tony
Todd is in both of them so you know if
you like him you want to check him out
but it just [ __ ] with the whole
mythology of the first movie well they
probably went more towards the slasher
they did is is quicker which for all you
okay
some people might like that because
you're going away from the Gothic or
more towards slasher but Vince on what
is inconsistent with yeah the tone was
gonna be it just seemed like they kind
of like [ __ ] up like all the mythology
I honestly I haven't seen em so it just
seemed very generic it did I mean
Candyman seems like it would just it
built this whole world around this urban
legend in this case
character and then it just seemed like
the sequel's just when did let's just do
like another half a slasher movie except
with this guy with the hook which meant
you know some people might like that you
know I haven't seen it's like yes
judgement
I don't like I'm just saying I haven't
seen any good reviews uh but sometimes
you know when I'm loaded I just wanted
em see you know to me something like
Friday the 13th to have ridiculous those
[ __ ] like just people like Tina's
getting really you know we went back and
watch the fried 13th I own what I think
I'm on the first three yeah only the
first two are good yeah I had forgotten
how shitty like they got bad the first
two weren't good they wrote although
they weren't great it was just good
although that one with Jason in space
was actually pretty hilarious an ex I
think yeah that's what I'm saying you
know I mean sometimes if you drink and
you just have a good time and you have
you know yeah if you have there's a
bunch of people with you maybe that's
more and they have to be bad enough to
daily to ever entertaining yeah they
can't just be like media bad good yeah
oh what another thing I was gonna say
too and I mentioned Jordan Peele earlier
as you know as this being like people
talk about like you know all the racial
not under tens but overtones like yeah
in town in Jordan Peele movie but this
did was doing it like a long time before
that this is back in 1992 this it was
yeah this is they were doing that before
this was cool yeah this is Burton it was
subversive really yeah it was breaking
new ground yeah because it it had a lot
of issues and it wasn't like subtle
about it either it was a horror movie
with damn interracial angle well then it
went a lot into like the residents of
cabrini-green which is a real place
you know it'll battle the gang were
feeling like a lot of the you know
inequality and [ __ ] like that it went
into a lot of that like you know like I
said a long time ago in 1992 so since I
mentioned Jordan Peele he is apparently
there apparently doing a remake or a
sequel of this that's going to come out
next year now I don't think Jordan Peele
is going to direct it but he is for sure
gonna produce it and he's gonna be
involved in some way um so I think that
might be pretty money good cuz he seems
like the guy to do that yeah because
he's like a big fan of the movie you
could update this movie today with
today's technology if you did it right
you know you could have a nice review
fast-paced story like I said they were
working within the frame
work of the day of the 90s when they did
this it was great back in those days but
today I already saw this movie too
that's another thing maybe if I was
young I've never seen this movie maybe I
would had a different impact yeah well
and the thing about it too is the 90s
were a slow time it was before social
media and little [ __ ] phones and [ __ ]
like that
you watched a movie sat there for
several hours to escape and there wasn't
much to do nowadays you know there's all
these other things competing for your
time a lot of these little movies I
can't sit through them see I don't have
a problem with that you know what I mean
horror to me I mean I like stupid
slasher movies as much as the next
person like it just depends on what mood
I'm in yeah but I think horror works
better when there's a lot of buildup
like you know what I mean when it gets
you like invested in the story the cool
thing about Candyman the original is
that you care about both characters you
care about Helens character you care
about Candyman you sympathize with him a
little bit because he got a [ __ ] raw
deal and [ __ ] life and you can
understand why he's mad so you know that
there's sympathy on both sides and
that's you know the story is so
compelling that and you sympathize with
her later on because she's getting
framed for murders that it appears she
did not commit so you can put yourself
in those shoes yeah um and I like that
they kept Candyman back until like the
halfway point of the movie and then just
introducing very slowly who would play
Hank Candyman today though I don't know
Idris Elba maybe yeah he could probably
do it yeah he's got a good voice oh yeah
the guy that was British that well he
can do an American accent southern
American accent yeah but uh that that
was the first person I thought of was
address elbow I liked all his work
Deborah dark tower yeah dark tower that
was but that wasn't his fault he was the
only good thing and yeah he made that
movie better he did but that was I the
problem with that movie was that they
shouldn't have tried to get that make it
in the first place yeah because yeah
there was a series it can't be a movie
they can't spit and that movie wasn't
even really based on any of the milks
exactly they just took like bits and
pieces
three of those books and there's nothing
from those books in that movie no it's
just like I said it was just like oh it
was almost kind of like Oh set in the
same universe type of thing you like it
felt like they were doing that but so
yeah I'm kind of like I'm normally I'm
just kind of like oh god a remake or
whatever now this might not be a remake
it might be a sequel I'm not really sure
cuz because I think when I was reading
about it they said well it's gonna be
like the baby Anthony that got kidnapped
in the first movie that he's gonna be
grown up now so I guess it's like a
sequel but it's also still about the
urban legend um they said that they
might get Tony Todd back for Candyman
but he says he understands if it's if
he's like too old and they have to get
somebody else but he would be excited to
be a part of it so we'll see how that
goes I mean like I said I love Jordan
Peele so and he seems like the guy to do
this to tackle this kind of material
because it's very similar to stuff that
he usually does so we'll see how it
turns out but like I said if you haven't
seen Candyman you really need to check
it out also check out Clive Barker's
short story they're forbidden like I
said they're kind of different but um
you know the frame or the story the same
it's you know it's just set in Liverpool
instead of Chicago and you know the
character of Candyman is a little bit
different but other than that it's
pretty similar but yeah check it out
it's on Netflix at the moment they just
added it for October cuz it's Halloween
and that's the time everybody's watching
[ __ ] horror movies man's ago and
check it out